well here it is the long-awaited sequel
that everyone thought wasn't going to
happen just because I want to make other
videos in the meantime the incorrigibles
honc based on the redheaded stepchild of
the MCU that was universally considered
math and then more or less stricken from
the canon and ignored by everything
except agents of shield all we assign
you to Barrow Alaska and you'll spend
the rest of your years pulling the night
shift guarding blonsky's cryo-cell which
is also extremely ignored this movies so
unloved it couldn't even get a passing
reference in Luke Cage which takes place
in the same part of New York where the
final act of this movie exploded like 10
buildings so it's already prime material
for an adaptation from a bygone era of
gaming where every major movie release
had to have a shoddily produced video
game tie-in to generate extra hype an
era where the movie cast was
contractually obligated to mutter their
lines as the same character with a
sleazy corporate executive named Todd
breathing down their neck in the
recording booth and they clearly only
did it for a paycheck and didn't want to
be there because they thought gaming was
a cultural dead-end for storytelling an
era where a movie studio would tell a
development staff that they had to rush
out a game as fast as possible' for it
to coincide with the movie's release not
understanding that game development is a
painstaking and laborious process that
requires finesse and years of careful
crafting to pull off correctly nope get
it done in eight months or we'll sue
which resulted many of gaming's most
forgettable and sometimes most
embarrassing moments the culture
surrounding gaming really did grow and
improve when they stopped doing these
kinds of games and just started being
their own thing but this game is a
particularly bad example of this era
from top to bottom it feels rushed
sloppy undercooked underwhelming lazy
and the worst sin any game can ever
commit just not being very fun coming
hot off the trail of Hulk ultimate
destruction radical entertainment began
work on the long waited follow-up
prototype which has the same amount of
creative and polished gameplay including
some mechanics lifted straight from
ultimate destruction and then refined
for a more nimble protagonist this movie
tie-in was then handed off to a
different developer no one has ever
heard of called edge of reality who at
the time were known for the show
tail game that's great good work later
on they would develop transformers rise
of the dark spark which killed another
great licensed game series you just keep
knocking it out of the park guys I know
I fought tooth and nail not to review
this game but the people have spoken
and my plan to get you all talking about
something other than spider-man games
worked too well I guess I think one of
the biggest things keeping me from
wanting to play more of this game is how
unpolished and grotesque it feels
aesthetically the graphics look
unfinished with some areas feeling like
a preset map in gmod waiting for you to
load up a bunch of rag dolls and jeeps
to crash into them the draw distance is
abysmal and not 20 feet past your face
can you see cars trees and people just
appearing out of thin air like they were
summoned by a sorcerer or trying to
confuse you into thinking this shoddy
simulation is the true reality
and speaking of shoddy simulation the
worst character models in the game are
the ones based on actors from the film
it's like there are two clashing art
styles in this game because the
characters that are from the comics look
a little more exaggerated in comic book
II while the contractually obligated
Hollywood people look like sentient wax
statues with grossly detailed faces and
plastic hair the attempted and failed
realism juxtaposed with the stylization
just makes both look especially bizarre
together and it's hard to even watch the
cutscenes because of it on top of that
the game's general atmosphere is just
kind of gross to look at it's like
everything is the most ugly shade of
brown grey or green they could find it
all has this yellowy tint on top of it
this game's aesthetic as a Michael Bay
film that's been microwaved and had old
lemonade poured on it even the main
character is hard to look at well he
looked
serviceable in the film this design for
the Hulk is really hard on the eyes and
the form of a slap together video game
model circa 2008 he's just too muscular
like have you ever seen a picture of
someone online that's so muscular their
body proportions are now all out of
whack and it feels like their everyday
life would be actively hampered by being
that shredded like your brain realizes
on first glance that it's unnatural and
unhealthy to be this bulky and you
instinctively wince at and look
this version of the Hulk looks like that
to me and he sets off all kinds of
alarms in my lizard brain it's just a
game that's thoroughly unpleasant to
look at for long periods of time I have
to play these games a lot to make these
videos staring at this polygonal virtual
trainwreck gives me a headache but as we
know graphics never truly make the game
and it's all about gameplay did they at
least get that part right No remember
how smooth and controlled the movement
felt in ultimate destruction where you
got a wide variety of ways to reverse
large spaces and you can do pretty much
every normal gameplay mechanic while
also in a full sprint none of that is
here we're back to the Hulk being too
sluggish but at the same time also too
slippery these controls feel odd because
the Hulk's moment-to-moment actions are
all too slow like punching and grabbing
but his locomotion is very slippery he
seems to glide around a lot while trying
to do basic things like a punch
imagine having weights strapped to every
part of your body so all of your
movement was really slow but you also
had rollerskates on to compensate so
punching a smaller enemy like the
soldiers can be kind of difficult
punching anything that's capable of
moving is difficult because the Hulk
just slips and slides past them or they
do the same thing and accidentally move
out of your path the best strategy is to
wait until they're completely stationary
orient yourself towards them then just
keep your hand off the joystick and
Hammer the punch button so like the
combat works as long as everyone
involved is standing perfectly still in
one spot you can't run up buildings and
instead have to do this slow and floaty
climbing animation you can't - while in
the air but you can punch to achieve a
similar effect though it barely gives
you any forward momentum the jump and
sprint kind of happened independent of
each other so it doesn't feel like
you're chaining them together when
moving it's just like deciding which
slow and unexcited method of transport
you want to take so jumping from a
walking speed gives you the same amount
of momentum as jumping from a sprint and
neither feels satisfying the ability to
wall run and sprint into a jump or dash
and hit the ground running made the
travel feel so easy in ultimate
destruction but now Alex Mercer is over
here
doing that and the Hulk is left with
nothing it makes you wonder if radical
patented some of these gameplay
mechanics in the studio making this game
wasn't legally allowed to copy them or
if edge of reality just had far less
experience making these kinds of games
and didn't have the time or resources to
recreate that motion in a new engine I
don't know who cares this will make
those spider-verse views you don't care
they didn't care no one cares yes you
can still do the awesome boxing gloves
out of a car thing from the other game
it was kind of an obligation since the
movie referenced it but the animation
for activating it is a little slower
than an ultimate destruction so it feels
sort of like it's killing the flow of
gameplay speaking of killing the flow of
gameplay this game's framerate slows
down if you do literally anything you'd
think it's because of the amount of
things breaking into a million pieces an
exploding on screen plenty of games
start to lag a little when too much is
happening on screen at once but now even
sprinting around at night in the empty
streets and not hitting anything makes
it get choppy and slow it's like you can
run so fast that the game isn't finished
loading stuff ahead of you and starts to
chug a little to catch up so it's
especially bad when you're sprinting
around in combat and effortlessly
walking through the environment like
it's made of wrapping paper nothing in
this game feels solid it's like a world
made entirely of cardboard filled with
nitroglycerin it also looks like that
two things touch the Hulk and just
explode and you'd think that would make
you feel pretty powerful right no it
doesn't give the effect that the Hulk is
strong just that the environment is lead
it would make more sense of things
weren't so flimsy because then you'd
feel like you were actually doing some
damage if you broke it anyway even if it
was strong cars are destructible and I
guess it's kind of neat seeing the
amount of pieces they break into but
they can make themselves fall apart just
by hitting each other running into
buildings in fact this city is so flimsy
that it practically destroys itself you
can just go stand in an area of high
traffic and the cars will infinitely
swerve into each other and everything
else every time they come near you you
don't have to do a damn thing but stand
there
no wonder the Hulk feels like he brings
destruction and violence everywhere you
can't even go through the crosswalk
without something explode
kinda hilarious just watching everything
go berserk due to banners mere presence
look this same civilian NPC gets hit by
a car and go skidding down the concrete
on his face twice in a row and just
walks off with a limp in fact the only
thing that's really indestructible about
the city is the people you can't kill
them no matter how many times you punch
them or how far you throw them they just
get up and hobble away I guess they
didn't want the Hulk to seem like too
much of a monster charlie is that you
in addition to the military the Hulk
must also fight a militia of sci-fi
soldiers called The Enclave
who fight the military and try to
experiment on New York with evil comic
book science including creating most of
the boss characters they're run by a
group of color-coded scientists that
have no personality so even the colors
can't distinguish them their weapons and
vehicles are identical to that of the
military and when you're just fighting
their soldiers they look exactly like
the military guys because the graphics
aren't that great the camera is so
zoomed out I think these guys were added
just so that there was someone the Hulk
could smash other than just normal
soldiers following orders Johnny Marine
over here just got out of basic training
two weeks ago and can't wait to finish
his tour to get back to his high school
sweetheart Diane to finally marry her
but then he gets sent on a mission to
u.s. soil to fight an irradiated
screaming pile of muscles only to have
his head bashed in with a punch at the
force of a freight train and have his
bones liquefied as he tumbles lifelessly
across the concrete so let's also throw
in some stormtrooper as bad guys that
actually deserve to be ultra punched I
guess they didn't want the Hulk to seem
like too much of a monster the open
world map as discussed earlier feels
flimsy and unfinished but it's at least
an attempt at capturing New York instead
of whatever this island was an ultimate
destruction the city feels as though
it's kind of empty most of the time and
traversing it is a little slow so they
give you these fast travel stations in
the subway I can think of another game
where that was more thematically
appropriate can you imagine the Hulk
taking a subway me and
do you underground with hundreds of
people in the most aggressive city in
the world
let's get a cab some areas of the open
world map are so empty that you might
think it's a loading error and that a
building was supposed to be there but
those places are really just meant to
look like that they give you side quests
in a system that matched pretty closely
with the spider-man 3 game I think most
people spend the bare minimum amount of
time on them because they aren't very
engaging the actual story quests feel
very grindy and repetitive with very
little payoff most of the time this game
takes a long while to finish but not
because there's a lot of content it's
just because they knew how to stretch
hardly any content as thin as possible
the bosses are a mixed bag for me it's
kind of cool having to fight so many
different unique characters at the same
time with the UFOs though it's clear
that one of them is just a reskin of the
Hulk fun fact sometimes this and other
boss characters will spawn at random and
the open world map to fight you if he
caused too much destruction but I saw
this guy get his butt whooped by a
generic enemy type look he almost beat
him he's just won because he had more
health the hold buster boss fight is one
of the most tedious and boring ones I've
ever played he just keeps blocking
everything and you can only stun him
with this type of move that takes
forever to charge up and sometimes he
might just block that too it takes ages
to actually land a hate on the guy and
then you have to beat him three times in
a row the rest of the enemies in the
game are pretty much just reskin to the
halt himself which I guess is comic
accurate at least how do you make a
villain that can be a physical match for
an 11 foot tall brute made of five
hundred percent muscle just make another
one with different skin or clothes by
beast is pretty cool because he's at
least bigger and has some different
types of attacks plus it's cool to have
some representation in this game
what are you kidding
are these real advertisements I can't
tell him oh my god that guy oh that got
me good oh let's stop talking about the
technical bugs for a bit and give some
attention to the narrative aspects of
this game the story is loosely based on
the movie except it's all set in New
York and Bruce Banner snatches the Hulk
the entire time except for a few brief
moments in the cutscenes there's this
really weird problem that the previous
two games were clever enough to sidestep
for the most part Bruce being in his
Hulk form the majority of the time makes
certain things unintentionally hilarious
like you as the Hulk travel to meet the
guy from Fantastic Four as Samuel Sterns
and then you turn back into Bruce Banner
while fully clothed to walk into his
house he tells you need something the
army has some data that would really aid
my analysis if only I could get my hands
on
here's the data outstanding
the gameplay creates this bizarro
paradox in the story where banner is
turning into the Hulk just to travel to
and from places then quickly turns back
into himself just before the
conversation starts and at that point
you got to ask is he really having a
hard time controlling it this question
alone kind of like destroys the whole
story other weird stuff worth mentioning
doc Samson is back in this one and
serves almost the exact same purpose as
Samuel Sterns so now the Hulk just has
two different kindly human scientists
Bros guiding into which things to smash
via radio and having him steal things
for them in two separate unrelated
projects and also the cutscenes are
noticeably stilted and seem to be in a
rush to the end but maybe they're after
that big green Hulk it's like they're
trying to get the dialogue out of the
way and abruptly end the scene as fast
as they can because it cuts back to
gameplay so quickly give it some room to
breathe guys jeez another screenwriting
rule is come in late leave early but not
bad early the boys cast feels like
they're all half asleep listen to
general Ross delivering relatively the
same line in the movie and the game
present concern that man's whole body is
property in the US Army as far as I'm
concerned that man's whole body is
property of the army don't even get me
started on Edward Norton's performance
it's shocking to see how far the Enclave
will go rendering an entire city
uninhabitable makes me angry very very
angry I'd like to preface the rest of
this by saying that he's one of my
favorite screen actors ever in several
of my favorite movies feature him as a
leading man he's an extremely talented
guy when he wants to be but I got a talk
about his voice work here
I'm sorry you know the sad thing is that
this would have been a relatively easy
job compared to the voice-acting
other live-action heroes have to do for
similar games Tobey Maguire had to play
a character who never stops talking or
like you know Robert Downey jr.
basically invented a version of Ironman
that was considerably more talkative but
the Hulk all Norton had to do was the
cutscenes and then 100% of the gameplay
is just Fred the last name doing his
trademark left for dead tank growls
[Music]
[Music]
but even then he's just fawning it in
super hard
I guess his voice acting sounds alright
in a Wes Anderson movie where none of
the characters speak above a soft indoor
voice and he's alright in sausage party
because he's doing a bad stereotype in
the joke is that the character isn't
supposed to sound like a real person but
Bruce Banner requires a little more
emotion than that Edward Norton is such
a serious method actor in live-action
roles almost at the point of being hard
to work with because he has such a
specific vision in mind for every
character he wants to portray but this
makes me feel like you just didn't take
it seriously at all and that's kind of
sad man I've got a little bit of a rant
coming on if you'll indulge me long
enough to segue into the celebrity cameo
I sometimes feel like screen actors
don't take voice acting seriously and
consider it beneath them or just a quick
paycheck the voice acting isn't just
reading lines into a microphone it's
actually really hard because voice
actors have to do everything a screen
actor does without even being seen even
if a character doesn't look human or
realistic at all good voice acting can
make us feel attached to them or view
them as someone real despite their
animated appearance a voice actor has to
convey a ton of emotion without the use
of their face so they can't just look
sad or happy or angry they have to sound
like they're all of those things and if
a voice performance doesn't work we
really can't tell what emotion the
character is feeling so seeing a game
where the voice acting is treated like
an afterthought depresses me a little
let's offset it by talking to a good
superhero voice actor in fact he's one
of the best thanks Savior I really
appreciate you having me on I'm I'm
excited to be here I love the stuff that
that that I've seen of yours online and
and and I love how glowing will you talk
about spider-man so so how could I
possibly turn that down alright thank
you so much it's such an honor I can't
believe that you're giving key just a
random goofball like me the time of day
hey I'm I've been meaning to ask could
you uh you read a couple of lines that I
have here as spider-man for me well
you'd have to you know get permission
from Sony and Marvel and a lot of
expenses involved I mean it could I
don't know I don't know
when you could let's just say it could
get expensive well can you do it as Ben
10 not legally you know Sasuke you know
I don't even know who you'd have to
email to get the rights to that one
how about axel the biggest little hero
oh that rolls too famous for this show
okay um who can you say this line is
that won't cost an arm and a leg and
take 12 months of paperwork I could say
it is myself that works okay hi I'm Yuri
Lowenthal and I am the bomb squad he
said it he said it wait did I just get
tricked no well kind of sort of maybe
but also one last question before you go
yeah a lot of people have told me that I
sound a little bit like a character that
you've portrayed which one Marco this is
so getting old and I just wanted to ask
you since you're kind of the authority
on the subject do you think maybe I
someday have what it takes to be that
guy you know what we are all spider-man
so yeah yeah I do thank you so much
mm-hmm appreciate it this was an amazing
opportunity and glad to have you here
happy to be here well nothing in this
video is gonna top how cool that was but
I'll be damned if I won't at least try
let's talk about some positives for a
moment there's a lot of daily bugle
signs in this game in fact they even
have the whole building in the Latvian
Embassy too and even the Baxter building
I wonder how complicated the contracts
were at the time to have gotten that
stuff in there jeez I mean I had to
email the PR people at Sony to even make
this video it's cool that there's a
decent amount of unlockable costumes in
here if you have a save file from the
Ironman game that came out right before
this you get an achievement you can play
as the Hulkbuster the design is kind of
a work in progress and the one
MC would actually use later looks a
little better but it's still pretty neat
not sure about the fact that 100 percent
completion in this game is impossible
unless you buy a separate product which
I did just for this bit in this video
man even back then the MCU is being
annoying about cross promoting itself I
can't say anything bad about Lou
Ferrigno inspired Hulk being here though
I mean I look at he's so cool driving AI
in this game is a beautiful disaster and
I wish we could mod it into other games
imagine cars being this quick to swerve
into the sidewalk in GTA 5 or the new
spider-man game someone anyone if you
know how to make that happen record some
of the shenanigans and send it to me
after a lot of unsuccessful boss fights
Emil Blonsky reads the Hulk's body
language and facial expressions to prove
he's the real killer then bleeds all
over the place and then becomes the
abomination Hulk's arch nemesis begins
wreaking havoc that's not very
noteworthy according to Luke Cage and we
have our final boss so it's very funny
it's a shame that much like Norton's
take on the character this game was
ill-fated and left behind I actually
think the movie is pretty decent I wish
they would have capped Edward Norton as
the Hulk
Mark Ruffalo just doesn't seem to fit as
well for the character in my opinion
though I think he does a decent job
anyway however this game was just yeah
there's a lot wrong with it and very
little to latch on to I know it's
probably not as bad as I'm making it out
to be but I feel like I have to be
especially harsh on this one because it
followed a game that was so polished and
well executed it's no secret that
ultimate destruction is one of the best
superhero games out there and a big love
letter to this character and it just
feels like this game is a cash grab
while the brand of the Hulk was still in
the mainstream consciousness do yourself
a favor and pick up ultimate destruction
as for this one
[Music]
I hope it was worth it
and then that now yes now
you
all right you knuckleheads I finally
finish this series thanks for being so
patient that being said I've got plenty
of stuff to work on still included
patreon requests and then just stuff for
me so stay tuned for those but what I
really wanted to talk about was how
grateful I am to Dan Givaudan the host
of The Amazing Spider tock podcast it is
seriously the only podcast you should be
listening to if you're a huge spider-man
fan they've had guests like Erik Conway
creator Punisher and one of the best
spiky writers of all time or Christopher
and your arms the voice of spider-man in
the nineties show and also a couple of
games or a whole bunch of other cool
people in the industry that was list
here and of course very talented mr.
Yuri Lowenthal dan is a good friend of
mine and he was kind enough to put in a
good word for me with Yuri so this whole
video really would have been possible
without him seriously go check out his
show and give him some support really
really deserve it
and obviously a huge thank you to mr.
Yuri Lowenthal for being on the show
hoisting is so many amazing characters
from my childhood it'd be one of the
best by the actors of all time and
encouraging me to follow someone by on
expirations
has meant the world to me and I
seriously just can't thank you enough do
you go the next time here's an app just
a quick reminder before you go that I
post my videos a day early on patreon
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
content and patron exclusive videos
please consider becoming a patron it
really helps me out if you want a more
short-term way to support the channel
you can check out my merch and the links
in the description we have t-shirts
phone cases posters mugs pillows baby
onesies and so much more
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]